okay so we just left the first pin hole
Star Wars Celebration JJ Abrams kathleen
kennedy talking about the force awakens
I have no words really I walked out and
I was just like just happened so first
let's just a little rundown of the panel
because obviously we're going to get to
the trailer but JJ and Kathleen came out
they talked a lot about what they wanted
to do with this film that they wanted to
focus on practical effects and then JJ
mentioned that he really felt like it
should be a fairy tale western and I was
so on board for that then of course we
got some of those practical effects to
come on to the stage we got to see r2d2
and bb-8 showed up which was so cool
rolling around the stage JJ had to like
calm them down a little bit they were
talking over him sometimes but the best
part about that is so Kathleen was here
at celebration and saw guys who created
those droids and brought them in for the
movie how cool and then we got to see
some of the actors JJ's like oh I could
tell you about the new ones that we've
added to the star wars universe or I
could have them tell you about their
characters and onto the stage walks
Daisy Ridley John boyega and Oscar Isaac
so they talked a little bit about their
characters not too much and if that
wasn't enough that we got some of the
veterans we got Mark Hamill Chewie Leia
c-3po all on the stage talking about
their excitement for this film and then
they're like cool awesome we'll take a
picture by Kathleen Kennedy stays on the
stage and she's like oh we're going to
give you a trailer it was awesome it was
everything that I possibly could have
expected the force was very strong with
this chick a hooker we obviously got to
see more from some of the new characters
but the moment that everyone is talking
about is the moment at the end we get to
see Han and Chewie
just looks at jillians as jewey for all
mom and the whole stadium disrupted
everyone was so excited there were tears
there were lightsabers in the air it was
epic so make sure and you check out the
full trailer and let us know what you
guys think on fandango movie clips i'm
gonna go watch the bunch more times okay